وكان وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس
كليبرلي قال ان لاوكرانيا الحق في استخدام
القوه خارجه حدودها من اجل تقويضي قدره
روسيا على استخدام القوه العسكريه داخل
اوكرانيا
من المهم ان نتذكر ان لاوكرانيا الحق
المشروع في الدفاع عن نفسها طبعا لها الحق
في فعل هذا داخل حدودها لكن ايضا لها الحق
في استخدام القوه خارج حدودها من اجل
تقويض قدره روسيا على استخدام القوه
الداخله اوكرانيا ذاتها ولهذا فان ضرب
اوكرانيا اهدافا عسكريه مشروعه خارج
حدودها هو جزء من عمليه الدفاع عن نفسها
موقفه وجد صدا في برلين حيث قال المتحدث
باسم الحكومه الالمانيه ستيفن ان القانون
الدولي يكفل الكيافه الدفاع عن نفسها بضرب
اهداف على الاراضي الروسيه واصفا الامر
بالحق المشروع كما قال
شهدت العاصمه اقوى الغارات والهجمات
بالصواريخ المستشار الالماني تحدث في
اتصال هاتفي مع الرئيس الاوكراني وبحث معه
هذا الهجوم غير المسبوق على كييف زيلينس
اكد ان الدفاعات الجويه قامت بعمل جيد
وكان هناك ضرر كما تعلمون ليس لدينا
معلومات بشان هجمات بطائرات مسيره على
موسكو في الواقع القانون الدولي يكفل
لاوكرانيا ويسمح لها بالدفاع عن النفس ضد
الهجمات الروسيه وهو حق مشروع المستشار
الالماني اوضح اكثر من مره وظيفه السلاح
الالماني هناك وهي الدفاع عن الاراضي
الاوكرانيه